here's what's happening in portland a
portland man
has been charged with arson after
throwing a large explosive
device at the hatfield federal
courthouse during a protest
on july 28 2020. investigation by u.s
marshals hq and atf
read more okay well we can read more
this is the this is the department of
justice they say u.s attorney billy j
williams announced today that gabriel
aguard berryhill 18
has been charged by criminal complaint
with using fire to maliciously damage
the marco hatfield u.s courthouse
quote no legitimate protest message is
advanced by throwing a large explosive
device against a government building
mr agard berryhill's actions could have
gravely injured law enforcement officers
positioned near the courthouse other
protesters standing
nearby or himself i applaud the atf
agents and the u.s marshals service
deputies
who worked quickly to identify mr agard
berryhill before he had an opportunity
to hurt others
the violent opportunists engaged in
dangerous acts of violence
such as arson need to realize there will
be grave consequences
said russell berger u.s marshal for the
district of oregon
serious crimes of this nature go beyond
mere property damage
to the courthouse and endanger people's
lives they say according to the
documents at approximately 11 50 pm on
july 28 2020
security cameras at the hatfield federal
courthouse captured footage
of a large incendiary object enter the
building's portico area
and land near plywood sheeting affixed
to the building's facade a few seconds
later the object exploded
igniting a fire near the building's main
entrance federal law enforcement
personnel collected various items near
the site of the explosion
and sent them to a bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms in explosives
laboratory for further analysis
they revealed social media posts the
night of the night of the explosion
and located videos of the incendiary
object being thrown the individual
depicted throwing the object later
identified to be a guard berryhill was a
young caucasian male
wearing a green colored vest now where
where did how does that sound familiar
huh
yeah grammy grammy's uh grammy's a
little scammy's boy hammy's boy it is
gammy's
antifa militant whose grandma bought him
a riot vest has been charged with arson
it's i believe the story is a little bit
too good to be true though
i don't believe his grandma actually
bought him the best
but so so for those that don't know the
context this guy right here
he was shielding naked athena like a
very cringe-inducing white knight
yeah and she's pushy she was pushing him
out of the way and he kept
shoving her and getting in front of her
oh man that's the most annoying thing in
the world
i'd have hit the guy like stop pushing
me and get out of my way
in fact i almost want like i i'd love to
have been there and just grab the guy
and be
like dude stop touching the lady yeah
it's like it's not even about defending
the woman it's about
this cringe white knighting that makes
me just so ugh
it's like dude can't you see she's
trying to get her photo op
all right i know like let the naked lady
spread her like to the cops
get out of the way let's get this over
with please it's more about this like
it's you know you know what used to call
behavior like this from these like white
knight dudes
bad farting it's a bad fart that clings
to you no matter how how much you try
and like shake it off it's just people
can smell it and they're like
oh yeah like you try to you try to run
out the room or something you're fanning
it just won't go away that's what this
guy is that's a good point anyway that's
what it looked like
so there's a website there was a website
where they
they sold this it's a it's a reflective
vest it's supposed to look like a
bulletproof vest
they're literally larping dude this guy
bought a larp vest
no his grandma bought it for him well
supposedly
right right right the post was made
eight days before people publicly
identified the guy and that's why people
are like hey this post is from a week
ago
it's and it was a verified review
meaning whoever left the review
did buy the product but it's possible
somebody bought the product they found
him they bought the product
because they they found here's here's
what i think happened
it was the the night before the 20th
where the naked athena lady did her
thing
and someone probably looked up this guy
found out who he was
and then posted his picture on this
website that's what i think happened
i'm not entirely sure it means they
would have had to buy the vest
themselves
a week later a bunch of people found the
profile
found the post and then we're like dude
this is the guy and now they believe his
grandma
bought him a riot vest it's not a riot
vest
it's a reflective vest for larping like
live action role play these this is
literally an 18 year old playing a game
yeah now he's being charged with arson
federal building i mean he lit i i saw
him light it
and throw it and that was the the big
huge explosion that we covered a couple
nights ago
it was like okay that is definitely
something more than just
whatever they were you know a firework
mortar you know it was clearly
something ied yeah an ied exactly it's
like okay
you play stupid games which to him is a
game
to everyone else is not a game like
someone could have been seriously
injured
this is what law enforcement does you
throw a bomb they arrest you
you go to prison and then other people
are like hey if you do that your life
will end this dude's life is over i'm
pretty sure what he did is a felony all
right
i mean i don't know exactly if they laid
out
okay so then exactly lay out if it's a
felony but i'm assuming arson on a
federal building
is going to be okay here we go they say
he made his first appearance in federal
court today before a u.s magistrate
judge
and was ordered released pending further
court proceedings what
really wow huh arson is punishable by up
to 20 years in prison
with a mandatory minimum of five years
wow okay yeah five years in prison dude
now now here's my here's the most
important question how long do you think
he cried for
i think he's still crying you think he's
still crying absolutely he probably
cried for quite a long time yep
and his mom probably gave him a spanking
and his dad was going like i have no son
what have you done
remember that antifa guy whose parents
brought him in what do you think he's
saying to his grandma
i can't believe i bought you that vest
what's his name is his name billy
you told me you told me it was gonna be
for larping
okay gabriel i bought you that rest and
now you're going to prison
it's all my fault gabey gaby
oh gaby you're going you're going to get
locked up no man
i think that's the gist of the story on
this guy but this is the perfect example
of what law enforcement does
and why we have many different
departments could you imagine if people
thought they could just do these things
and nothing would happen
that's the problem with what's happening
yeah we need to see these people
important like go to jail exactly
it's a combination of deterrence
i do think we need reform yeah
for sure we need i mean like prison
reform how do we make it so that these
people come out and they say to
themselves wow that was a really bad
idea i shouldn't do that again
that's a big so question do you think
you can connect this to the broken
windows theory of policing where if you
uh get people in trouble for small
crimes you will be able to
prevent them from doing bigger things uh
i don't i don't i don't know there's a
direct connection there i don't know
because i mean arson on a federal
building it's not exactly small i i
don't know
about the i don't know if broken windows
policing actually worked
there's like there's pros and there's
there's people who uh there's proponents
and opponents of it saying it did or
didn't work
there's an interesting thing i was
reading about at the time when they were
claiming
this new heavy-handed policing was
reducing crime we were actually removing
lead from gasoline
and like leaded gasoline levels
coincided with like crime or something
yeah i'm not saying it's true or
anything i was just reading an
interesting article they talk about
what you know it's a question of here's
the here's the issue when it comes to
policing
when it comes to broken windows freedom
or security
i i err on the side of security which
means you'll see lunatics get released
i think the big problem with cities like
new york is that if you simultaneously
can't defend yourself
and you have a ton of you know you want
to have
it's an imbalance in law enforcement
right you tell people
okay we're going to air on the side of
freedom bail reform what that means
is in new york they pass this bail
reform measure certain crimes you get
straight up released
we will not hold you because
you can't afford to pay bail they argued
it was unconstitutional to hold someone
else that money and poor people are
being negatively impacted
okay i agree with that actually holding
someone could destroy their life
however crime began to skyrocket why
because it's still
illegal to personally protect yourself
in new york city
in in certain ways to say the least
that's a good point so then you end up
with a bunch of very weak vulnerable
people and criminals being constantly
released
if you're going to have freedom it can't
be only freedom for one certain thing
you commit a crime you're free to go
okay what about my freedom to defend
myself from the criminals you're
releasing oh
no no no no no we'll lock you up for
that okay
and therein lies the main problem with
imbalance and
so i i are on the side of freedom i
don't like the idea
of you know pre you know proactively
going after people you know if they
commit a crime they commit a crime
yeah if they're walking around like
morons with shields okay fine whatever
if they then cross the line then you
arrest them then you charge them
but i do think we need to look at in
like uh how we do prisons and trying to
try to figure out a better way
i 100 agree privatized privatized
prisons are
definitely an issue you know them trying
to they
they want their it's it's an industry to
them
you know the people who own these
prisons and that's an issue like why
why are you making money off of of crime
like we have to turn we have to get rid
of that
some the the incentive they need to be
incentivized to
let people you know become citizens and
and and prosper
outside once they get released but i was
thinking about this i think the issue
might not actually be private prisons
it might be recidivism well that's what
i just said
what i mean is when we pay private
prisons it shouldn't be based on
them holding a prisoner it should be
based on in the next
after the prisoner was released did they
commit crimes in the next five years
and then that's what i'm saying we don't
give contracts to prisons who have
higher recidivism rates yes
or when when it becomes lower they get
more
they then get to prosper you know it's
like then they can use that money for
grants like the crime bill got rid of
people being able to further themselves
and
that's ridiculous to me like why
wouldn't we want them
you know at least looking to get grants
to like have a library
to finish their high school education or
get a bachelor's degree in something so
that when they get out they have
something to actually strive to
towards you know i think the the crux of
it when it comes to jails and stuff is
the system we have in place is like you
know we started in the wild west
we started okay we're gonna build a big
room we're gonna lock you in it you
can't get out
and then we said okay well we got more
people we need a bigger room okay now we
need a bunch more rooms now we need our
own building
now we need a bigger building okay now
we need to separate jails and prisons
so now we have jails for temporary
holding under a year then we have
prisons for everybody staying above like
more than that and it's just
then we have super max prisons all week
all we've really done has been like
let's keep making bigger and bigger
places to put people instead of saying
like hey let's
change the system and invent something
that could fix this
instead of just you know sweep it under
the rug
i think one of the ways to get there
would be if we have private prisons
perhaps we should be saying something
like if a high density a high proportion
of the prisoners released from your
prison
go on to commit crimes later on then
we'll stop giving you contracts
i like that and they're gonna be like
okay we gotta figure out a way to make
sure that the prisoners leave here and
never commit crimes again otherwise we
go out of business
and that might actually make sense
there's interesting ideas around voucher
programs um who's
who's the the the guy we talked to corey
and corey deangelis yeah corti angelus
talks about school voucher programs
yep i like it the idea is like if
everybody pays taxes for schools and
rich people pay more than poor people
but then everyone is given a voucher
that they can then give to
the school of their choice so their kids
their kids can go to the school they
want them to go to
it guarantees that poor people will have
access to schools any school they would
like to send their kids to
and you know it also guarantees the
right for uh
for people to choose their school while
having schools compete to be better
i actually really like that idea i do
too sounds promising yeah
for all i know they implement it and
becomes the worst decision ever and it's
complete in total chaos
yeah but i mean well to kind of bring
that into
the policing it's like unions the police
unions
the teachers unions they protect bad
teachers they protect bad cops
that's all part of this problem that we
until we
look at those and restructure those we
can't even really get to the rest of
this
because they're protecting the bad
systems that are already in place oh
yeah so we gotta we gotta really dig
into those
yep and they're they're an issue but you
know the the general idea is perhaps the
voucher kind of
thing could work across the board you
know
post offices or whatever yeah so i but i
look at
prisons and that's what we need we can't
just have the government be like okay
here's a contract take our prisoners
yeah exactly it's got to be like we've
got a couple different ones that compete
and whoever has the lowest recidivism
over five years gets the contract yep
i like that that's a good idea actually
so maybe i don't know maybe that's a
really bad idea i don't know the
solution is maybe there are some people
it's got to be
locked away because they'll never
improve
you know serious challenges with people
who just don't want to be
functioning in a society or can't i
don't know you should at least give them
a shot
seems fair at rehabilitation yeah yeah
well this dude's going to get five years
in prison and here i'll tell you what i
think he's 18.
i honestly don't think five years is the
right is the right goal
i don't think it will take five years to
convince this this young person
that what they did was wrong i think it
runs the risk of radicalizing them and
institutionalizing them in a way that
they can't function once they get out
now i'm not saying do nothing do you
think do you think he knows that he did
it wrong now
no i don't i think now he's going to
have a bunch of people whispering in his
ear saying c is in the state of pressing
you for no reason
imagine if you got a real point so we'll
see what the punishment is they say it's
a minimum of five years
which means there's no recommendations
there's no playing it's
unless they unless they drop it to a
lesser charge that's what i was thinking
i don't think it's going to be the
the you know the full arson charge
because nothing got lit on fire no it
did oh it actually did
light up very briefly oh okay yeah i
didn't know that it did yep i mean it
didn't burn down i mean it's
i'm not trying to say it wasn't okay to
do it but i'm sure it's not going to be
the full
arson charge with five year minimum i
kind of feel like that is the drop
charge
really yeah if they're giving them only
arson instead of like there's criminal
damage to federal property which is i
believe a felony okay
then there's arson actually that's part
of the executive
order if you attack a staff federal
statute a federal building it's 10 years
10 years minimum that's right so well
this is a is that does that include
federal facilities
i i don't know i haven't maybe i think
that was that was specifically like a
veterans monuments act or something
specifically
okay either way this dude could be
charged with you know
dozens of crimes and they're giving him
one five year minimum
so we'll see what happens when he
actually goes in maybe they'll you know
they're playing big ask and
they'll drop it down but i think we've
i don't know what the solution is when
you get when you get these dumb
i mean let's be real man this kid is as
dumb as a box of rocks
yeah he's playing well it was it was his
first time in the
in the court right isn't that what they
said well he had his first time for
these charges i don't know
okay okay but he's wearing a larp vest
you know like imagine if a dude went
he went and bought like a medieval night
suit and then marched around in chain
mail
they were i know there was nights out
there yes
like they're playing games that's what
they are they they seriously think it's
a game where they have no consequences
grandma grandma should have bought gabey
to a paintball range
yep and go play some paintball and get
it out of his system yeah
but you know what it is maybe these
people they thirst and hunger for war
and conflict
maybe we are we are animals all of us so
so what beings
what happens to this dude after he gets
out in five years i don't know
but i'd imagine he's not going to be
functioning in normal because he'll have
no idea how to function in a normal
society well if they get rid of the
police so
seattle's going to be a completely
different place i don't know it sounds
kind of funny maybe he'll fit in
oh yeah it's fun well i mean not if not
if you actually live there
oh okay like if you want to go i thought
if you want to go if you if you were
like i said these these
young men who are thirsty and hungry for
conflict yeah yeah they're going to be
like
it's you know going to the
post-apocalyptic you you like playing
fallout
well that that's what they're going for
they're going for fallout and real life
i like playing the game
[Laughter]
these people don't realize they're going
to be living and escape from seattle
right there's going to be like gangs
controlling everything there is
you i'm i got to be honest i'm there's
actually going to be a like cathartic
release
when i see a bunch of like pink shirt
wearing
dudes with skirts on and like flowers
around their necks okay
and they're going and they have like
community police in their chests
and there's one guy with like a hammer
and he's like
take the money out of the van no it's
like a brinks or like
the brink's truck please sir please no
you don't need to do this dude dude we
can all be friends let's hug it out
free hugs and then he goes whack to
their hand it's demolition man
yeah the cops walk up and they're like
that's a good point that's what it's
gonna be like
get get on your knees no what do we do
what i don't know wait
let me check the manual he said no it
says say the same thing
i can't find it in the manual what do i
do it's like he's like say the same
thing and add or else
oh yeah that's right i haven't seen that
movie in a while i gotta watch that
again what
that's a good movie but you look at that
uh i'll tell you what remember that
video of that of that chick
saying like our effing what the arrester
imagine there's no cops and she's just
stomping about screaming and smashing
things oh karen
and then you're going to have these
dudes wearing like pink shirts going
like
can you calm you can't don't you're not
supposed to break that oh she broke it
oh geez
um oh can you stop ugh she's good she's
not gonna stop what do we do let's get
out of here
and they run away i'll tell you what man
no they're gonna be like it's okay she's
oppressed yep
and then you're gonna be dude who
in their right mind would would want to
own a business in seattle right now no
one who in the right mind would want to
live there there's no way
i don't know anyone who would want to be
there and i feel bad for the people that
do live there yeah
i am i'm sorry man but i have very
little sympathy for the people who are
choosing to stay there
now choosing i feel bad though because
people people probably grown up there
they probably have lived they probably
have their whole lives there and it's
like
dude i don't believe that the majority
of seattle
wants this to be the case they don't
people called into a meeting screaming
like
we don't care for this radical
experiment and taking surprising
i'll tell you what man if you live in a
city and i don't know like a meteor came
and just like
crashed into the center of it and wiped
out a ton of the buildings and
infrastructure
okay and then you were like i'm gonna
stay here it's like
well you can that's fine but i mean
you're like living in smoldering ruins
by choice now well that's that's
an act of nature so ultimately here's
here's what bothers me
the people who keep voting for this
stuff
they voted for these people no no no
they they
they they voted it's like no no most
people
are comfortable in their lives they
don't think this is gonna happen
they get too complacent with what's
happening they stop
caring about the politics because but
whatever you know
that's what i was saying this won't
happen right you were explaining earlier
the majority is busy working they get
home from work
they crack a beer and hang out with
their friends they don't talk politics
politics needs to be a regular thing for
everybody and it's not anymore
these people that are out there doing
this it is
everything to them it's the only thing
that they do is because they want their
you know message pushed forward to the
front of the line and that's what
they're doing
so the people that live in seattle if
they want if
they want this by all means but if not
they need to get political they need to
get involved they need to be protesting
also
i'm actually thinking if biden wins we
might see
you know so let me stop there i'll start
over people believe
that if donald trump wins progressives
will go
nuts and start tearing things apart
they're already doing that right so
what's the difference but most people
are like yep the progressives they'll
they'll rip everything into shreds if
trump gets elected
if binding gets elected it's only like
36 to believe conservatives would get
violent
and that's like i'm like well those 36
are wrong
but maybe not i'm starting to think
otherwise thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you